au centre commercial où madeleine à ses
habitudes on n'aime pas que les gens
garé leur voiture dans le stationnement
pour aller prendre le métro juste à côté
et on l'indiquent clairement mais
madeleine elle y fait son magasinage
pourtant lorsqu'elle retourne à son auto
une mauvaise surprise l'attend un billet
pour stationnement illégal de 95 dollars
visiblement le surveillant regarder
ailleurs quand madeleine est entré dans
le centre
ça ne l'a pas empêché de remettre un
billet qui prétend qu'elle n'est pas une
cliente du centre commercial
regardons de plus près ce biais il
ressemble à un constat d'infraction
mais ce n'est pas un seul les policiers
et les agents de stationnement peuvent
remettre des constats d'infraction
ici il ne s'agit que d'un avis de
réclamation remis par l'entreprise qui
gère le stationnement
c'est n'a vraiment pas la même valeur
qu'une contravention et sane enclenche
aucun processus judiciaire madeleine
peut simplement contacter l'entreprise
et l'informé qu'elle refuse de payer
cette réclamation frivole le fin mot de
l'histoire
ne vous laissez pas intimider par les
gestionnaires de stationnement privé
fait la différence entre une
contravention et une réclamation